mere feet away live and in person
about what mr shovin is doing to mr
floyd
so that foundation we will be able to
lay through his testimony
all of which has been disclosed and and
will be offered for those opinions
so we would ask the court to deny this
motion
i think at some point it becomes a
medical opinion and so and i don't think
the state
is offering it for that purpose for
example that it was the hold itself
which contributed to the death of mr
floyd
uh it appears to me that this is
actually similar to the firefighter
where this person can talk about their
training and experience
and specifically i think in this case
because he does say
and it is audible on the video
that the terms blood choke
i think he is entitled to say what his
experience is
and to explain what he meant by that
and also the shimmy to be honest
that that's what he thought he saw and
that he thought it had gone too far
because in his training once a person is
unconscious i assume this is what the
you're talking about mr frank that once
he's unconscious that
the hold should be lifted that's his
training he's not don't pine on
anything else he can't say this is what
causes death
this has caused him to go unconscious he
can do talk about his observations
and based on his experience that he
thought it was a blood choke hold
that he wasn't uh seeing a shimmy to
explain what those terms mean according
to his experience
and i would even allow him to say and
based on his experience he thought that
behold was kept on too long
and beyond that worse then we start
talking about medical
opinions did it cause the death did it
cause him to be unconscious um i think
he can talk a lot about his observations
and explaining
what he thought about the hold itself
and how that it went too long does that
is that kind of clarify for the state
where i'm drawing that line
it does right mr nelson all right let's
move on to the next
thank your honor the next motion is
number 23.
i think this is again very similar to uh
the motion yesterday involving genevieve
hansen
again we're not contesting that
firefighters who responded to the scene
can testify as to their observations
as to the course of medical treatment
that they attempted to
to use the process
for mr floyd ultimately it's just their
opinion
as to what the cause and manner of death
were
i mean that's what i'm seeking to
exclude all right is the steep
attempting to do so mr blackwell
good morning again your honor morning no
we're not and
it's mostly just to be clear about sort
of what we mean
we talk about you know cause of men or
death or not
testifying about any contributing
factors you know what does that mean
uh the paramedics are obviously there on
the scene
uh doing everything they can to revive
george floyd's life we've been without a
pulse for several minutes
and the jury is entitled to know uh what
they
uh how they reacted to what treatment
modalities they decided to employ
which ones they decide not to and then
when they get to hennepin county to the
emergency
room uh where they will be further
attempting to revive this deploy
what they reported uh based on their
observations and experience
so that's actually and and that is what
we would intend to
impart to the jury on how is this
different than the rulings i made on the
off-duty firefighter i don't think it is
uh whether a person's off duty or on
duty when they have virtually the same
qualifications i would allow the same
type of evidence
accordingly what the firefighters saw
when they arrived
uh the symptoms they saw whether medic
the person wasn't medical distressed
what techniques they thought were
appropriate to intervene
all the things that i said for the
off-duty firefighter i think apply
equally
uh to the other one it's just
observations of what they saw
what uh attempts were made through
revival or resuscitation i think it's
the same
line as drawn as for the off-duty
firefighter
okay very well yeah thank you
mr nelson
here i think we could probably um
quickly dispatch at number 25 and 31
as well 25 being
uh
exclusion of any reference to mr
chauvin's invocation
of his fifth amendment rights
i had a brief chat with mr frank just
for point of clarification
we are not seeking to suppress any
statements that were made
or that were captured on body camera
footage we agree that that's admissible
and in fact we've repeatedly stipulated
or offered to stipulate to the
admissibility of the body-worn cameras
from the incident likewise
uh other officers capture conversations
and their body cameras for example
a sergeant responds asks what happened
audio it's non-testimonial we're
stipulating that that all comes in
ultimately when this turns to a critical
incident however
mr chauvin is brought to room 100 of the
city hall which is the standard practice
in critical incidents here in
minneapolis and is
afforded an opportunity to consult with
a lawyer at that time
the lawyer who responded they didn't
make a statement
and i believe ultimately we are in
agreement
that there would be no reference to the
invocation of the fifth amendment rights
at that point
beyond anything that had that happened
before that's captured on body camera we
agree is admissible
mr frank uh sounds like we're in
agreement
yeah with our understanding that that is
sole
basis of this motion we would agree that
the council decision
to not give a statement is off limits
so you're saying that you could somehow
elicit
pre-custody that he did not give a
statement
well there there are pre-custody
statements and lack of statements
that would not be covered by the fifth
amendment correct
i think it's always complicated uh with
a peace officer in this situation with
the castigar and garrity of
the statutory protections so it's not
like a civilian on pre-arrest
silence there's all these other statutes
that protect them and
has everybody thought about that
well i would say not fully your honor
because i i'm not sure of the
extent that those cases would apply to
the very situations that
mr nelson was talking about so
so ultimately your honor the the
prior to him being brought down to room
100
before this was deemed a critical
incident
everything is captured literally
everything is captured on one body
camera or another i don't believe that
those
constitute garrity statements they're
not forced
statements they're not being you know
he's talking with officer king or he's
off
talking with officer tao at the scene
no officer no authority figure from the
police department is compelling him to
make those statements i don't think
garrity applies in
that context again i agree all of that
is within bounds
anything that is or isn't set but in
terms of
saying once he gets to room 100
and a lawyer is afforded to him and a
lawyer counsels him
that's the basis of the motion um
i think it would be improper for example
if
the state says well mr chauvin
didn't make a statement to
his sergeant in that instance that is
i think that would be improper and also
in this situation statements were made
he was standing there right next to
the other officers who were involved
when they gave the public safety kind of
statement about what happened
and so so again i think that's all
admissible
i would agree that that's all admissible
but an inference that his
silence uh in that circumstance
would not be proper i mean
all right i think
yeah an adoption of a statement
by silence would still be
admissible is not prohibited by this
so what we understand council to be
saying is
he is not raising any issue with respect
to anything
said up to the council decision
at city hall but we do not agree that
if there were adopted statements or you
know
silence statements by silence prior to
that point that they would be covered by
the fifth amendment either
and the case law that the court is
talking about well
i mean i guess i'll just leave it at
that because that's our understanding of
the motion
well i think i was referring to when
critical incident is a term of art that
we all use and i think when you start
declaring a critical incident it kicks
in
potential guarantee and castigar issues
it's but it sounds like you're not off
you're not intending to offer
any evidence of uh science
free arrest silence during between it's
a critical incident
to arrest where are you
all right we're gonna have to probably
have a
conference off the record when we get to
that point in trial
so i'm gonna reserve ruling i think
everything up to
all the body cams etc up to the time of
a critical incident
you would agree mr nelson that all is
appropriate
i agree okay and the state agrees with
that
it's that question of critical incident
declaration to arrest
pre-arrest silence but does the fact
that it was declared a
critical incident so let's talk a little
bit more about that
when we get to that point in trial but
those are the limits for now
and if you have any other authority that
you can throw my way out and i may be
sending you down a rabbit hole i
recognize that uh but
i would like to make sure we cover all
the
unique aspects of this situation
okay thanks and i think we can also
quickly deal
with number 31
which is a motion to exclude the
statements of officers tau
and lane and for points of clarification
we officers talwin lane gave tape
recorded
voluntary statements to the bca and
in connection with the fbi counseled by
attorney
they find criminal investigation ones
understanding that their statements
can't be used
or could be used against them that's all
i'm talking about i'm not again
talking about what's on the body camera
footage or those statements
i believe based on the submissions the
state has already
agreed to that they agree that that's
testimonial evidence that i would not
have the ability to cross-examine those
other witnesses
i confirmed with each of the attorneys
last night that they are not permitting
their clients to testify in this trial
i would have no ability to to
cross-examine those particular
statements
anything else again i think it's fair
game
is the state intending on offering any
of that mr frank
we would not offer them
but there is the issue of expert
reliance
i suspect both sides experts have relied
on those
so i just want to make that clearer
well i think they could say that they
have reviewed the statements
of those officers that they but then
i mean and i know things could be
admissible to show
the basis of the officer's opinion or
the expert's opinion
but i think uh you know
i'm not going to do it unless you get
permission from the court at the time
and show a good need to actually get the
substance to form the basis of the
expert because the expert's
testimony is not supposed to be used as
a back door to get in
otherwise inadmissible hearsay
okay so just be clear i will allow your
experts to say they did review those
statements
that's it at this point
and then we have um number 26
which is a motion to exclude any
testimony or
reference to um a blue line of silence
or some sort of conspiracy of police
officers to remain silent
and not cooperate with investigations
of other police officers i believe in
this case
a there would be absolutely no evidence
of that
every single police officer made
statements they all cooperated they all
went into the bca or the fbi they made
statements they were represented by
attorneys again
so there is no lack of cooperation by
the minneapolis police department in
this case
and i think that any reference to that
would simply be to try to inflame the
passions of the jury or create some sort
of a
conspiracy that that the officers um
are just trying to cover them cover
themselves or protect one of their own
state's response
i think as long as we're picking up your
voice on the microphone uh
you can stay there maybe pull the
microphone soon
yeah i would say that
well by and large the minneapolis police
department and its personnel have been
uh professional and cooperative um
i think it could be argued we cannot say
entirely
but by and large for the most part we do
not intend
for instance an opening statement to
make statements about
a blue line or something as represented
in this motion
however we cannot be
our position prohibited at this point
from
raising you know bias if that becomes
apparent during testimony at trial
and that is possible and so
i think this motion is in that sense
then premature
because you know it should be determined
on a witness by a witness basis
if bias comes up that looks like this
during trial we should be allowed to
explore it
for that particular witness perhaps
but these are loaded rhetorical devices
that have been criticized by many hearts
because it is
clamory to talk about a wall of silence
a blue line in fact i think the original
thin blue line
phrase came from a defense attorney
talking to a client
being pressed in line that protects us
against
or protects civilization against uh
energy
so actually i think its origins are not
in prosecution
and the problem is it's a rhetorical
device that is inflammatory and goes
towards culture and
i'm unlikely to allow you to do it in
any case but
if you think it arises as necessary and
as evidence of bias
uh let's do a sidebar and decide that
right now i cannot conceive of
when this type of rhetorical device is
appropriate
so we'll go with that
and i believe we had number 33 or is
there another one
just 33 years left yeah and just you
know just for the record
all of these motions in lemony are based
on the record as we currently know it
things in trial happen differently and
so if you think a door has been opened
or
otherwise um there are other
circumstances which change
we can always do a sidebar to revisit uh
if the circumstances call for it
understood okay mr nelson
your honor then uh the last motion we
have agreed to deal with today is number
three which is
their childhood their education their
career
photographs of the family family members
and discussion of their occupation all
that comes from evans
i think really morrow is one of the
cases that does a nice job
of describing some of the case law but
it really gets to
um you know this term spark of life
which i always
thought came out of graham you know
decades ago that the
the person that we oftentimes just gets
referred to as victim is actually a
human being
imbued with a spark of life that this
puts some
you know personal nature back into the
case for somebody who's treated to him
personally
you know unfortunately by the system and
so courts have allowed this when it's
for that purpose not unduly inflammatory
or prejudicial
and so we fully intend to do that
with respect to mr floyd we will have
photographs
of mr floyd at various stages of his
life
we will have your honor i think two
witnesses
that would qualify as spark of life
because one is a family member
who would talk about
mr floyd mr floyd's family and his
growing up and
being a brother to this witness
and you know as
many people know during the incident mr
floyd references his mother
and so there will be discussions about
that why that was so important to him
um another spark of life uh witness
we'll talk about
more contemporaneous things in mr
floyd's life since he came to minnesota
um and quite frankly we'll also cover
some
factual elements based on we we
foresee as you know attempts to sort of
denigrate mr floyd's character
this person will also be addressing uh
some of
mr floyd's life and um
so it really will be somewhat factual
outside of spark of life
when you say you anticipate that there
will be
evidence to denigrate mr floyd's
life why am i why i think i've been
pretty clear i'm not allowing that maybe
denigrate was too strong of a word your
honor i apologize
um you know obviously his drug use
is going to be an issue in this case the
defense you know is going to portray
that as a cause
and that becomes part of the medical
case then
so there will be discussion about that
there will be some evidence about that
and so that's why i want to be clear
that you know
one of the spark of life witnesses is
certainly going to talk about more
things
than just what's typical and covered in
spark of life but she will do that as
well
so just to preview that for the court um
you know
that's what we anticipate doing we will
not
um well let me see this way we
understand what opening the door means
and uh and we will not run a follow that
though there is some chance that we may
ask the court to
give us some guidance on that
specifically when it comes to
that testimony at that point in the
trial just to be
clear with everybody about that
yeah i think we are all familiar mr
nelson i'm going to ask you
follow-up questions in just a second uh
we're all familiar with
i think the spark of life doctrine that
essentially like you say that
this is not just a person who we label
victim and we de-personalize the person
that
mr floyd in this case is entitled to
have the jury realize he was
a human being he was loved he had a
family
i agree with all that i think if it's
basically evidence
that will not call for cross-examination
i think that's generally
well within the bounds
i guess uh and i don't
have a problem with two as long as we're
not spending too much time there's also
the case law that says it should not go
on and on and become character evidence
i'm not allowing a lot of the past
that would amount to character evidence
and i'm specifically concerned here
about and it may be true i'm not saying
this but you know that mr floyd was
described as a gentle giant
as soon as you start getting into
propensity for violence or propensity
for peacefulness
i think then we're getting into
character evidence and then that does
open the door for the defense to
cross-examine about
his character for peacefulness
everything else
how he grew up some pictures that he was
loved that he was a wonderful
father brother nephew all that stuff i
think is permissible
obviously if we don't go on too long
because it distracts from the merits and
then what happened
but that's my concern on the line is
that as soon as we start getting into
character evidence number one
i don't think for for a principle
because it's not i don't think you're
you don't get a chance to offer
peacefulness to the victim until they
the defense claims that the
uh mr floyd's case was an aggressor
at the beginning and we have videotape
to show what actually happened
as far as aggression or not
does this make sense mr frank what
i guess what i was trying to get at
earlier um
is to me it's not opening the door if a
witness says
he was loved by everybody of course he
was
fun to be around he enjoyed life we did
things together we went out
we had fun that doesn't open the door to
the kinds of things that
the court has ruled and admissible
otherwise absolutely so
it was there i was saying you know let's
have that conversation if we think
there's a problem
before you know before we're calling
that witness and putting them on the
stand
because they will talk about that and
they will talk about him being loved
and being a family and jury
had some some problems he was dealing
with in his life
we'll talk about that and that you know
will lead into these other
factual issues about the issues in the
case well i think if for example you
mentioned
uh the use of drugs and if there's any
discussion of
his struggle with uh drugs that's
certainly i think permissible spark of
life
it does not open the door to a lot of
the things that we've been talking about
my concern is because really if
he struggles i don't see that the
defense has the ability to cross-examine
further about that
um i can't think of it at least
i'll put it this way if you think that
opens the door you better
have a sidebar about that because i
don't see it as discussion of
use of drugs does not open the door to
further
past acts in my view for example
it does not open the door to the may
16th 2019 case
but my concern was more descriptions of
his
character for peacefulness because that
i think would open the door
to the may 16th case and other priors
that we're aware of because it's proper
cross-examination
you say x what about y so
that's my that was my big concern about
the spark of life i think everything
you've described is perfectly
permissible
uh in sparkle life testimony
nelson um
i just uh kind of your thoughts uh there
yeah why don't you go to the lecturing
it's a little easier
yeah i mean i agree um and that's that's
the
question is because a lot of what we've
seen in the media and
descriptions um would i think open the
door
to impermissible what you have ruled is
impermissible character evidence
but it would certainly open the door the
issues
you know that were ultimately
surrounding his drug use and his drug
abuse history
do play a very central role in
ultimately
the cause of death did he have a
tolerance for a particular
drug would that tolerance somehow uh
make levels that were in his system
more survivable to him does that make
sense
trying to be as opaque as i can at this
point well let's put it this way if the
medical examiner says that
such history of drug use could affect
their opinion
as to whether drugs were a cause of
death
i think it's permissible my guess is
they're going to say
whether or not he was a
drug addict with a long history of drug
abuse or he was
this was the first time he ever used
rice it wouldn't have made a difference
on their opinion
then i don't think you get into the long
history because
it's not proper examination if the
doctor says doesn't matter
that's not relevant to my medical
opinion i don't think it's relevant
for us to get into it but again i'm
predicting
i don't know what the doctor is going to
say i don't think we'll be in a
situation where anyone's saying it's not
a relevant concern
on either side let's let's deal with the
bounds of the
drug addiction evidence uh when it comes
up
okay this actually is why you'll notice
on the trial schedule
um i have the jury showing up by 9 15
to start at 9 30 but every day we are in
session at nine o'clock to talk about
legal issues
this is kind of what i've reserved it
for is fleshing out
the motions of lemony in real time and i
believe then
on with that that actually would
dispatch with another one of the motions
the defense motions eliminate uh which
one is that uh
i'd have to lose we can get rid of
another one that's fine
number 35 your honor
i think that covers the state degree
it's reserved basically until we get to
that point right
this is one i think we need to
sort of work through a little more
because what we're
alluding to trying to be i think opaque
as mr
nelson mentioned is tolerance
to some controlled substances is an
issue
experts will talk about in this case
so the finer points of motion 35
really need to be talked through and
quite frankly i thought we would
probably be able to
arrive at some stipulations about what
comes in through this
what is underlying number 35 i think
what it comes down to is
if an expert says that tolerance is an
issue or is relevant to a diagnosis or
their opinion it's some aspect of it
will come in then
but unless and until somebody says it's
it's relevant to their
diagnosis their opinion for example if
the state's witnesses say
doesn't matter it's not coming in if the
defense expert says
it does matter then i think you have a
right to present how
what the actual state of affairs was
yeah and i'm happy to work with mr frank
to try to resolve it through some
stipulations
and i think that again i think the court
is wise and it's decision to reserve
yeah i think we're going to reserve it
then but you kind of know where i'm
thinking the line might be again that's
why
we're going to be nine o'clock not eight
o'clock after the selection
so i appreciate your uh working full
days here right now
all right anything uh
i think that was it for today right mr
frank anything else we have
that's it for today around okay
uh we're going to take a a 10 minute
break let's come back at uh
at 5'2 and we'll start i think we have
juror number 20 who is our next year
and we'll start with that at uh 5 to 9.
all right we're in recess thank you
i think they're just finishing up the
orientation video for the new jurors so
all right let's go off the record then
yeah
all right mr shaffer would you get your
number 20 for us
all right come on up have a seat
[Music]
and you are juror number 20 is that
correct correct all right
uh before i turn things over to the
lawyers i want to go over a few things
first of which is i have to swear you in
so that all your answers are under all
so if you can raise your right hand
you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that
you will truthfully answer all questions
about your qualifications to serve as a
juror
i will all right thank you uh you filled
out a questionnaire and thank you for
doing that and taking the time and
submitting it
uh are there first of all was everything
true on that questionnaire
yes all right is there any change or
additions you want to make because
or even change and when i say change
because sometimes you'll
fill it out and then you realize after
you've submitted it that oh i
forgot about this or that and so i
really would like to change
something anything no all right when the
lawyers are asking
questions it might inspire something and
you might say oh yeah
i did forget that this is not a problem
this is the natural way that the
things work out you give it your best
shot at the beginning and then
things come up so feel free to volunteer
that extra information absolutely
as it stands right now though you don't
have any no
okay and now you're not supposed to read
articles and i think that was in the
questionnaire avoid media coverage of
this you've been able to do that
yes for the most part okay and and i'm
glad you say for the most part because
no matter how hard people try some
inadvertently
expose some a headline um
somebody says oh did you read this and
they tell you about it
and since you're not supposed to tell
anybody you're potentially sure it's not
like
right correct any of that happened that
you received more information about this
case from media or anybody else yeah
and the reason why i said that was just
um you know
where is trump going that's it
okay so maybe that the timing and
but nothing about the substance of the
case or the parties or and not too much
into detail though
okay excellent uh
you did have some knowledge about the
case before
uh you were summoned uh as most people
all people have uh understand that if
you are on a
jury in this case that you must make
your decision
based on only what you hear and see in
the courtroom that
what is actually in a do you think you
could do that
yes essentially put aside the things
you've heard
and put aside also in your opinions
because it's okay to have an opinion
based
off on the media it's not okay to bring
in
and make a judgment based on your
opinion uh
that isn't evidence yes
okay uh you were given a long list of
witnesses did you recognize
any of the names on that list yes
there's one okay um
a member of the bca i'm friends with
casual friends with
um that was on the front page here i
started here uh do you remember the name
uh yes it is mackenzie anderson okay and
how do you know um we're friends of
friends place in
college so 15 years but very casual
um actually after i saw that list i went
back in my phone when was last time i
contacted her we had contact
it was over a year and a half ago two
years so obviously no
discussion about the case and have not
spoken with her in
a year or two okay and have you talked
to her about her work
what she does on a day-to-day basis yes
but never before
um this case okay that makes sense you
know what i mean and what does she do
i believe she's a forensic scientist
okay general term
do you think that that uh relationship
or maybe
general knowledge that she's imparted to
you and you just
you know casual discussions do you think
that would affect your ability to be
fair and impartial in this case
uh i don't believe it'll affect that no
and i was thinking about it especially
in her line of work
forensics it's very science it's not
very
something where you have to try to get
something someone to believe something
right so i don't believe it would affect
that now
all right thank you um there is one item
on your questionnaire i did want to talk
to you about
and that's the length of trial and uh if
you are selected for this jury
we will start with opening statements
and evidence march 29th we anticipate
it's gonna be about four weeks so
pretty much into april and i notice you
say that uh
you're potentially getting married in
april
tell me about that i believe at the time
i i'm still getting married i believe at
the time of the questionnaire we did not
have a date we have selected a date
of may 1st um so that does give me a
little bit of cold feet about the
situation of jesus if this goes
four weeks it's going to bump right up
against that
well and we never know how long correct
yours will be in deliberation
and so do you think that if you were in
deliberation
is there a lot of preparation made for
this um so it is a
uh wedding located in florida um it's a
smaller wedding but there would be
30 family members going um you know
flights have been booked
um it's not a huge financial undertaking
where we're spending tens of thousands
of dollars on something that would go
away but
it would be an inconvenience and
obviously not the way you want to
spend your wedding date right right and
the question comes up you know i
i hope we are done by may 1st but with
deliberations as i said
uh do you think that would be like
you'd be going we got to make a decision
here because i got a wedding to get to
my own
uh i i don't believe so i mean i think
uh if i am part of this jury i think we
would have to make
accommodations um for that date
i would probably operate under the fact
that if i'm on this jury
i will not be able to get married on
that date okay
like that's me answering my fiancee
i'm going to go out on a limb and
suggest that she does not want to be as
accommodating
but i appreciate your probably but we
understand uh the process and what needs
to happen
all right i'm uh i'm going to pass it to
the lawyers then
they'll ask some questions so juror 20
if you would mr nelson
good morning sir good morning
uh just to refresh your recollection my
name is eric nelson i'm the attorney for
mr chauvin
uh thank you for your patience yesterday
and for coming in this morning yes
um so what i'm going to do sir is just
ask you some kind of general
questions get to know you a little bit
and then i'm going to ask you some
follow-up questions about some answers
on your uh questionnaires okay with you
yep um it's i know it's been a while
since you've read
read this so um if there's anything uh
that you have a question about
we'll talk about it okay thank you all
right
so um let me ask you this um if you and
i were to meet in some social situation
what would a couple of things you want
me to walk away knowing about you
uh about myself um i'm a i'm a father
i'm a devoted father
into sports music uh
i'm guessing if we ran into each other
at a social situation it would be with
beer at a bar
maybe before or after a game or a
concert sounds good
um and when you first received your jury
duty notice or your
summons for julie duty what was your
initial reaction when you saw that
um just a standard reaction i don't
think anyone ever gets a jury duty
notice and goes hooray i got jury duty
but
i've never been involved in this process
before so just standard you know run in
the middle okay my my number was up and
now i have to um uh participate in
durian
okay and how about when you learned that
it was uh potentially as a juror in this
case
yeah that's um that changed a little bit
where um
i obviously know the gravity about this
case um and when i first read that
that first line about the case i kind of
took a step back and went well
you know this is a big deal okay um
what what what were your thoughts what
were your con did you have concerns were
you
no um concerns wouldn't be the right
answer i mean just again the
the um the magnitude of this case i
would think
is is what struck me you know wasn't a
oh no
i can't believe i'm going to be
participating in this case or yes i get
to participate in this case i think it's
just the magnitude of the case
sure how about when you got to the
government center yesterday
and saw its current condition
yeah i think it just further solidified
the magnitude you know and reading that
juror letter
um and then seeing it in person like
okay this is you know the magnitude does
match what i had going on in my head
it's playing out in real life right um
do you have concerns for your physical
safety
uh not really no um and i know that's
not a yes or no answer but
um obviously again back to the magnitude
of this case
i know there's a lot of people watching
will be watching
um but i don't why awake am i going um
i'm in fear of my safety
on this case great um did it
comfort you to some degree to learn that
you would remain anonymous
yes at this point at least
okay great um so i understand uh based
on your questionnaire that you
again don't say the name of your company
we're trying to protect people's uh
identities here at this point um but i
understand you're in
like sales management is that correct
correct yes
how many people work for you uh i work
with the team
uh that's a a tough question i probably
work with a team
uh of about uh 20 people across the u.s
okay uh do you meet with them regularly
talk to them regularly
yes in your professional life can you
think of a circumstance where
um and i'm gonna back up for a second
are you in like a management role of
that um
no not necessarily uh more of uh
managing the data providing information
to our sales team across the country
so um can you think of a situation in
your professional
life or your personal life where you've
been called upon to resolve a conflict
between two people
um yes i'm sure uh again
uh probably to very less magnitude
for what we're hearing this in this room
but uh yes
right so i guess the question is is how
do you
how do you what are what are the tools
that you use to try to resolve conflict
yeah i would i would say you know
definitely a very logical person here
both sides
try to go with with what is the best
direction going forward
eliminate emotion as much as possible is
what i would use in my professional life
okay now in um kind of in a similar vein
have you been called upon
in a conflict resolution to kind of
determine which
person is telling the truth someone come
two people come to you
the first person says this is what
happens the second person says no that's
not what happened this is what happened
right uh outside of a five-year-old
fighting with his cousin not
really um again other than
what the general public would come up
with but nothing jumps out to my mind of
a
complete resolution of trying to find a
truth so keeping it at that simplest
most basic form a five-year-old
right um how do you how do you determine
is my son telling the truth or is his
cousin telling the truth
yep correct so hearing the argument you
know uh uh
hearing uh them talk through what
happened
and assess the situation maybe you know
step by step
and you know determine who you would go
with of who's telling the truth
okay um have you
can you think of a situation in your
life where you were 100 certain about
something
only to later learn that you were wrong
oh i'm sure
um i i can't think of a specific uh
uh experience but uh i'm sure there's
probably at some point in my life where
i was
in conviction of something and it was
not true okay
um are you the type of person who's
willing to keep an open mind
yes so one of the things you'll
ultimately be instructed in
is that you have to follow the law even
if you disagree with the law
do you think you can do that yes right
now i i understand
your fiance is a lawyer or graduated
from law school correct
again without saying anything is she
practicing law
no does she have an intent to practice
law
i don't believe so okay um
but obviously she has an education as an
as an attorney she has a juris doctor
right yep um and if you were to be
a juror in this trial and you were to go
home and you heard some piece of
evidence or you heard some
ruling of law would you turn to her and
say
you know the judge said this today can
you explain what this means to me
uh i would not you know i i respect the
system and what is expected of me as a
juror
uh um and just knowing to handle the
case within
you know these four walls is what's
expected of me so um
i'm sorry i'm not sure you phrased your
question but i do not find a problem
with that
okay um so you would agree that you
could follow the law even if you
disagreed with the law
correct and you wouldn't try to glean
any sort of insider information on
rulings that the judge may make from
your fiance is that fair to say
yes great um
any concerns regarding uh covet
um no i mean other than uh
and when going back to maybe the the
timing of the case uh and again
when scheduling a wedding during a
covered era we are under the impression
that you can never schedule anything
more than 48 hours out so
in terms of covid concerns it would be
if there was a copen incident and the um
affecting the case timing you know if it
would have to be delayed or
paused for a week i don't even know if
that's possible or what would happen but
um for concerns that would be the only
one okay
um now i'm going to just turn to your
questionnaire again i understand it's
been a while since you've
reviewed it um
you've obviously you're familiar like
all of us
with this case correct yes and you had
um i believe answered that you'd viewed
a particular video
the facebook video or the viral video
two to three times yeah that sounds
about right i would say
maybe once in its entirety and when i
say entirety i
you know correct me if i'm wrong i think
it was about six or eight minutes
i don't think it was from start to
finish but um i probably made it
to the completion of the video one time
and i've probably seen clips of that
uh two more times okay um and then
obviously maybe
little snippets in the media and things
of that nature yeah
but outside of uh maybe a you know a
screenshot on a headline that's about it
okay and have you um
you've it's fair to say you formed some
opinions about the case
uh yes a bit of again watching a video
obviously you
have an opinion when you watch it and i
tried to share that as best i could in
the questionnaire
yep and um i guess what i'm
questioning is is that you understand
that that's just one piece of potential
evidence in this case yes
absolutely um and you may see
multiple other camera angles you may see
multiple other
pieces of evidence i mean i think you've
seen the witness list right it's almost
400 people long
are you willing to kind of hear both
sides
pay attention to all of that and keep an
open mind
um about all of the evidence not just
that one video
yes because you did indicate in your
questionnaire that you were
you had a somewhat negative opinion of
what you saw in that initial video
yep absolutely
um and you provided a written
description
and you say um you wrote that before
during and after being placed into
custody mr floyd appeared to be under
the influence and somewhat
unruly did you see other videos in
connection with this case that
may have made it to the media um no okay
how did you how did you form the opinion
in your mind that he appeared to be
under the influence and unruly
uh i
been having a little trouble with that
statement
um i think i've just heard through
the the case that um i'm assuming when
someone's in handcuffs they're in
handcuffs for a reason
uh but no i did not witness or see
unruly behavior
so to speak during those videos so i
mean you you have received information
from other sources friends
family members colleagues i mean people
talk are talking about it right well i
think um uh
yes and no but that that information for
me
is the um both sides of every argument
angle right is
is obviously you see a person um
who dies in police custody that is a
very negative
connotation and to me sometimes i wonder
well who would be on the positive side
of that right
and and the term that would have been
used was
there was a reason he was placed in
custody and and that would be where that
uh sentiment would be placed from fair
enough
and i think that that you answered there
was a question that says have you talked
about george floyd's death with your
family friends co-workers discussed it
online
you indicated that you had and that
you've shared the feeling that you felt
the event
did not need to end in his staff correct
ultimately you would agree that you
would be able to would you agree
that you would be able to put all of
your personal opinions
what you've heard kind of off to the
side and decide the case
on the evidence that's presented in this
court yes
um the there is a question about whether
you have ever personally seen
the police use more force than was
needed and you answered yes
watching the television show cops
correct so and the reason i
i say that is i've never witnessed it um
in person
but i have witnessed that television
show many many times in fact my
my dad and i used to watch it all the
time and you do see
physical force being used within that
show okay and
whether it was more force than was
necessary i guess perhaps is
a question uh sorry what was going on
the question
was whether it was more force than was
needed
correct and this is coming from a viewer
at home not having all the data
sure okay
i want to ask you
briefly about your relationship with
miss anderson okay
um how did you get to know miss anderson
uh so one of my best friends in college
was friends with her in high school
um so kind of a friend of friend that
started probably in college
we remained friends for a couple years
she went to grad school
and weren't really in a
close talking relationship a few years
ago
we played a rec league volleyball team
together
i believe for two summers one or two
summers um
but again haven't spoken to her in in
probably a year and a half
and obviously nothing about this case
perfect so i guess my question
because you had said something when the
judge was asking you about it about
you know you know what she does for a
living and
um that her role probably would be
somewhat minimal
and not minimal necessarily but somewhat
uh i'm trying to remember the phrase
that you used but that she wouldn't be
attacked her credibility would not
necessarily be attacked correct i think
i phrased in the form of
her position in the bca's you know
revolved around
science and facts so when you talking
about someone testifying
it's not really a witness that do i
believe this person or not
it's usually something that someone with
this background professional background
will be sharing something that's
that's hopefully supported by science
right okay so let me ask you this
hypothetical question
interruptings
you